on commence avec les entreprises on veut
le faire d'une façon très graduelle
d'une façon intelligente avec toutes les
règles que le doctor who d'or nous donne
donc on travaille sur ce plan là où vos
proies vous en parler dans les prochains
jours mais on commence vraiment par les
entreprises avec nous ce soir
eric girard ministre des finances il est
à québec dans son bureau me suggéra
bonsoir bonjour est ce que je comprends
bien donc vous travaillez présentement
un scénario de réouverture de relance de
l'économie
oui mais il ya plusieurs personnes des
petits bien sûr la santé publique
plusieurs ministres ont eux aussi des
parties externes et puis on consulte
opale aux entreprises aux syndicats
il ya vraiment plusieurs parties
prenantes finances douchy lol c'est la
première fois qu'on a le plaisir de se
parler depuis le budget c'était dans
l'ancien temps le budget on
al'impression le 10 mars dernier
depuis ce temps là il s'est passé
tellement tellement tellement de choses
est ce que vous devez refaire votre
budget 2021 mais en fait il y aura un
énoncé complémentaires
probablement
vers la fin juin qui va finalement
mettre à jour la prévision économique
pour l'année 2020 redonner un un cadre
financier ajusté 1 puisqu'il y aura
clairement moindre revenu les dépenses
et éventuellement un déficit alors on va
faire sauce un énoncé complémentaire je
vous dirais que les le budget avait son
utilité dans ce sens qu'il a permis de
rappeler aux québécois 2019 a été une
année exceptionnelle au niveau de la
croissance des finances publiques qu'une
somme en traîneau ce cadencement en
position de force
et puis des choses qui tiennent toujours
la base de dépense à 5.1 pour ça on
avait déjà un budget qui était prévu
expansionniste c'est donc toujours
appropriés et qu'on avait prévu 130
milliards de dépenses en infrastructures
c'est toujours pertinents mais là vous
êtes 5 point de départ de croissance de
départ mais est ce que vous allez
nécessairement accéléré augmenter
davantage les dépenses compte tenu de ce
que coûte cette crise là en fait ce qui
se passe c'est qu'on doit faire des
gestes supplémentaires au niveau de la
santé c'est indéniable bien servi le
fédéral c'est beaucoup concentrés sur
les individus et les entreprises et nous
on a fait des ajustements pour les
individus mais les entreprises mais
beaucoup la santé la santé est une
responsabilité provinciale
alors oui on avait des dépenses
additionnelles dans la santé et la
relance de l'économie alors tout ça va
faire un tout petit pas être supérieur à
ce qu'on avait prévu
et donc on fera un déficit de combien
selon vos projections et selon ce que
vous disiez aussi dans la presse ce
matin avait en fait nous on
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on
réfléchisse sur ce qui se passe et c'est
très difficile de faire un estimé
tellement il ya qu'on a vu lac la banque
du canada a refusé de donner un estimés
pour l'ensemble du canada pour 2020 mais
nous ce qu'on constate c'est que
approximativement 40% de l'économie
aurait été arrêté durant
approximativement 8 semaines et à partir
de cela en fonction du rebond de
l'économie de l'évolution nos
partenaires de la pandémie alors il ya
beaucoup des certitudes supplément d
hypothèse criminelle
on pense que le pib du québec bat
voisine et -5% en 2000 est associé à
soho avec les dépenses supplémentaires
la santé les formes la relance
d'économie on devrait avoir un déficit
autour de 12 à 15 milliards en 2020
12 à 15 milliards donc ça représente
trois et demi pour cent du produit
intérieur brut
je sais déficit des fuites ou vous allez
respecter la loi sur l'équilibré
budgétaire en allant chercher l'argent
dans la réserve de stabilisation
laurent dans les particularités
comptable des finances publiques a lancé
effectivement ap contribution au fonds
des générations de près de 3 milliards
de dollars d'une part et d'autre part
effectivement la somme des surplus passé
qui était la raison des de stabilisation
observée au niveau comptable à et
projets ce difficile mais ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est lorsqu'on compare
la situation avant la pandémie a après
la pandémie en prévoyons un seul budget
à l'équilibré
et maintenant nous prévoyons 12 à 15
mais la loi sur l'équilibré
je sais que c'est terminé c'est
important maintenant la loi sur
l'équilibré budgétaire sera respectée ou
faudra changer la loi
non la loue avec respecter auquel la
réserve à venir éponge il est difficile
est-ce que des nouveaux programmes qui
pourraient être adoptées pour le
tourisme par exemple
quatre cent mille travailleurs d'un
secteur touristique en soirée et la
saison sera catastrophique on s'entend
est ce que des programmes particuliers
que vous pourriez adopter prochainement
oui mais sait on voit consulter
l'industrie touristique on aura une
table de consultation spécialement avec
eux même chose pour la culture c'est
certain que c'est des industries sont en
difficulté mais à la base on essaie
l'avant des programmes les plus généreux
possible c'est à dire qu'on veut à aider
tous les citoyens et toutes les
entreprises et on va regarder si
effectivement pour ses industries le ya
des besoins mais jusqu'à quel point la
crise actuelle cause des changements
structurels à l'économie de québec
mais ça c'est une question intéressante
parce que l'eau durant la crise
hier beaucoup de gros de d'intérêt qui
annonce qu'il y aura des changements
structurels et donc il faudrait donner
la priorité à un des éléments que
favorise moi je pense qu'on doit d'abord
gérer la cuisse
par la suite on va se concentrer aider
des gens à france concentre sur la
violence et oui à des changements
structurels
par exemple je tiens j'en ai nommé 1 ce
matin dans journal l'industrie des
croisières
c'est clair moreau un changement
structurel dans tout ça mais il faut pas
il faut d'abord gérer la crise à 20,2 de
vouloir tout modifier le jean taille il
ya plusieurs groupes d'intérêts qui
communiquent avec nous au pont due à la
crise est dit que nous devons faire ci
ou qu'il y aura un changement
j'avoue que nous on est dans le
dans la gestion de la crise on se
concentre également à se préparer pour
la relance des économies et les
changements structurels vont
effectivement né il y en aura il y en a
qui étaient déjà là qui vont être
accélérés par exemple les achats en
ligne
on était en présence ça va être accédées
très bien monsieur girard merci beaucoup
pour cette entrevue ce soir merci merci
bien